there are so many games on game pass you
got sea of thieves you got skyrim you
got wolfenstein too you got zuma zuma's
revenge and then add game pass ultimate
with ea play into the mix and you're
probably like yo hold your horse's xbox
i don't even know where to begin in this
wild ocean of gaming's best deal and hey
that's okay cause rest assured we have
the list for you the best xbox game pass
games to check out right now alright
let's kick this off for the scarier side
of game pass
and what scarier game to get this train
to spooky town roland than visage
imagine if a small team of french indie
developers decided to try and pick up
where hideo kojima's pt left off and
well uh that's exactly what visage is
even though yes it's very clearly a pt
clone what's truly impressive is how
developer sad square studio managed to
evolve and stretch kojima's concept into
something terrifyingly all its own it
checks all of the boxes housed with a
gruesome and tragic past hallways i have
no interest in exploring but ultimately
have to and this cutie most inspiring is
the lambrinthian maze of the house and
how it constantly shifts shapes and
morphs in maddening ways as you go
deeper and deeper into the haunting
twisted storyline
what's the deal with big houses that are
so damn eerie anyways well in resident
evil 7 it's not ghosts that's for sure
it's the damned baker family there's no
denying resident evil 7's got a little
pt influence in its dna too which
uprooted the survival horror franchise
and put it in terrifying first person
and boy did it work
it only came out a few years ago but
resident evil 7 has already found its
place as a modern classic in the
survival horror genre and if you haven't
braved the louisiana swamps to take on
the baker family just yet then well what
are you waiting for an invitation
welcome to the family song
but who says you gotta deal with
monsters alone visage and resident evil
7 are single-player games but back for
blood pits the horde of horror against
you and three others it's the spiritual
successor to left for dead which means
you'll be blasting through massive
hordes of the undead or ridden as
they're called in the game and having to
think on the fly to communicate with
your team to take on special ridden
types like exploders who
explode or bruisers
who will
bruise you this game goes camping
because it's intense so you might want
to pair up with your friends or
strangers on this one thankfully though
you don't have to play with others if
you don't want to because it's got a
solo mode so don't worry you can be as
anti-social as your heart desires and
while we're on the subject if horror
games is your jam we did an entire list
detailing the best horror games you
should consider checking out right now
so you can find a link to that video in
the description below
[Music]
alright let's lighten the moon now shall
we the good life is a lot of things it's
an rpg it's an immersive sim you can
also take pictures make money on social
media to pay off your debt uh you can
also farm ride a sheep oh and uh
everyone in this rural english town just
so happens to turn into cats and dogs at
night in fact uh so can you
[Music]
oh yeah and uh there's a gruesome murder
mystery of foot did i mention you can
challenge a priest to a drinking game
the good life tries to be a lot and
while it doesn't quite nail everything
it attempts it makes up for it with
bucket loads of charm its characters are
quirky and memorable the story is
unpredictable and whimsical and it's
probably the most relaxed i've felt
playing a game in a long time there is
really quite nothing else like the good
life out there
psychonauts 2 it's the sequel to the 16
year old cult classic that continues the
story of the circus acrobatic psychic
prodigy raspberry but don't worry if you
haven't played the first you're in luck
psychonauts 2 gives a snappy recap and
does a great job of welcoming new
players to this marvelous world it's an
ambitious take on colorful 3d
platformers one that tells an impactful
and emotional story while also carefully
handling and approaching topics of
mental health in light-hearted and
considered ways
the forgotten city is definitely
something not to be forgotten it's a
time loop narrative game where you find
yourself in an ancient underground city
which is at the mercy of a fantastical
curse that kills everyone if one of its
citizens commits a sin however someone
is exploiting the power to wind back
time and it's up to you to experience
its final day over and over again until
you solve its mystery what unravels is a
thoughtful commentary on what's right
and wrong beliefs religions and morality
itself
it's pretty heavy stuff but is easily
digestible thanks to some incredibly
well written characters it's a marvel of
game design and writing working in
incredible tandem and one not to forget
about
and speaking of being ancient have you
ever heard of a game called mist yeah
like the 1993 mist well it's on game
pass but this mist is different from the
geriatric classic that came out 28 years
ago this one has been built from the
ground up in unreal engine giving this
oldie more than just a facelift but
completely updated visuals and controls
making it the quintessential way to
experience an absolute og mist is an
adventure puzzle game set on a
beautifully surreal island this game is
notoriously cryptic and a little
difficult but i assure you when you
imagine to figure out these puzzles on
your own and you will you'll feel like
an absolute genius
even better its soundtrack has remained
completely unchanged further proving
that new age music from the 90s remains
forever timeless just like enya
you know how you hear stories of people
who go off into the desert for like
eight months and experience this
euphoric spiritual awakening where they
suddenly understand the meaning of life
the cycle of existence all its
dimensions and that whole knowing in
that you know nothing stuff
anyways that's basically what it feels
like to play tetris effect connected and
best of all you can have the spiritual
awakening with a bunch of friends like
some meditative retreat because it's
multiplayer and it's just cool and stuff
hades isn't just among the most
innovative roguelikes out there it's
also the sexiest
hades uses the concept of dying over and
over again and uses it as a vessel to
unravel the story changing the
expectation of death is something more
than just failure but a rewarding
prospect and how the story is told
it's a hack and slash dungeon crawler
and for a while hades was pc and
nintendo switch only so having on game
passes a gift from well
the underworld
microsoft flight simulator strap in and
fly anywhere in the world the game uses
real world data pulled from big maps to
inform the in-game ai to generate the
whole damn planet this franchise has
been exclusive to pc until this release
so the console edition is a marvel in
and of itself
now of course there's loads of games on
game pass and these are just a few you
should try out so be sure to check out
the other lists on game pass games to
play in the description below
okay thanks for watching until next time
see ya
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you